all right welcome to another ideas that
matter conversation I have here uh Jimmy
Nutz AKA James Nutter uh also you can
find him at the fantasy nut work which
is a YouTube channel where that's how we
connected and interestingly enough the
Jimmy nuts thing if you put it into
Google you're gonna find that he uh was
still is or or just was retired retired
okay there we go retired pro wrestler
who has done over a thousand matches uh
had a career spanning 10 years so we're
going to talk quite a bit about about
that but but we're probably going to
focus a bit more on uh speculative
fiction so you know sci-fi weird fantasy
I mean looking at the channel so you you
say that you're interested in sci-fi and
fantasy but you cover other things as
well I think some horror is in there
um what other genres I mean there's
another question I've got lurking in the
background before that are there any
other genres that you're you're hitting
on in the channel because you've got
quite a few videos out oh yeah yeah so
I've been doing uh YouTube for book
reviews for almost four years going on
now and uh all various types of content
long form content interviews with other
people who enjoy it authors uh and a lot
of book reviews and I do primarily love
me some fantasy and sci-fi or
speculative fiction as we call it but
yeah you're right I like some horror and
I really have fallen in love with a lot
of
um just literature from from long ago or
even not that long ago I'm a big okay
I'm actually a carthy fan what they
would call Classics right I mean Cormac
McCarthy's I I think too recent to be I
would say he he's more of uh well you
know now that he has passed maybe he can
be up for that uh but certainly one of
the greatest American authors of all
time but I've I've been really enjoying
lately Russian literature and I've been
reading a lot of Leo okay story so uh
that's one of my probably in a new
favorite author for me is Leo tolsto
I've really really enjoyed his short
fiction uh the death of even Elliot
which I would say incorrectly I think
it's literally maybe the most
um visceral experience I've ever had
reading a book I read it on a plane and
it gave me an existential crisis and I
spent the whole week in San Antonio just
like staring at the ground like oh what
is this for you know so that means it's
a good book
yeah dealing with the infection of
meaninglessness right it uh reminded me
a lot of a book called the human uh the
conspiracy against the human race by
Thomas Legato oh yeah fantastic book and
very very much goes into the idea of the
Consciousness is a curse
just uh totally off topic but since we
brought up legati
um that is what we're doing for worlds
of speculative fiction this month
that and then a few of the collections
of short stories and try to see what you
know what we can put together about some
sort of shared universe but with that
that one we've actually got a
non-fiction book a set of essays that we
can
work through
um and yeah it's pretty cool stuff now I
was actually when I was thinking about
genres so some people include superhero
fiction in uh speculative fiction and
it's not quite the same as like the
whole world of wrestling but you know
wrestling runs on character and drama
you can't just get two or four or ten
guys in a ring in you know outfits
um bonking each other and running around
and stuff like that and having actual
interesting thing they got to have back
stories yeah and beefs with each other
and all that kind of stuff so I I'm not
going to say that it's exactly the same
as superhero fiction but it seems like
there's a connection or at least a
continuity there I mean well as somebody
who's like I'm sure thought an awful lot
about the practice a little bit over the
the decade that you were involved what
do you think yeah I mean apps absolutely
it goes back to the very easy premise of
of good versus evil and and what that
plays out like and someone who does
stand for True good and then someone for
True evil and just like for instance the
fantasy genre which has found its home
in a more Grim I would say possibly
nihilistic realm uh where things are a
lot more gray and nuanced uh you know
wrestling has evolved into that but at
its at its core you know we are telling
this the angel story that still sells
tickets to this day which is good versus
evil and just like uh you know even
someone that does comic books or someone
that writes a book there are tricks of
the trade to accentuate that drama and
and those feelings uh from the
audience's point of view so I I think
you're 100 pretty close and I played
very much a almost a Clark Kent type
role I I still embraced my nerve you're
a very very clean cut you know yes yes
and uh you know the whole idea with
Jimmy knots was um let's go nuts was the
idea so I came out I was very chipper
ready to have a good Fair contest and
then the bad guy would get up on me and
then I would uh you know go nuts as my
merchandise would say and mess up the
hair a little bit get a little rough and
tough uh you know kind of like Superman
going into the booth and coming out so
that that is a connection that I had
personally and I always thought Superman
was pretty cool even though I'm not
super into Comics now or anything but I
said you know that transformation like
when you know it's time to really throw
down that's whenever you know business
is about to pick up and I tried to uh
you know display that with my character
in in my body language
did your character over that that long
period did you have any which happens to
some wrestlers they're they're good guys
but then like they go off track and then
they have to have like a Redemption Arc
so is that what happened certainly yes
so you know I wrestled for many many
different people or businesses or
federations whatever you would like to
call them I wrestled All Over America
and uh more times than not I was the
good guy but I I was known to play a bad
guy or what we call in the business a
heel right yeah and to be honest we
actually think I was better at it and I
think that's just because I'm kind of a
sarcastic person and it's very easy for
me to get underneath the people's skin
you can ask my wife I am so good at
getting underneath people's skin
including her
um when I would wrestle in Canada uh as
you can imagine I would be the Arrogant
American arguing with crowd members
about bacon yeah versus Canadian you
know ham and Canadian bacon everything
else so depending on the location I
could be considered uh a bad guy for
sure interesting did it change with
regions in the United States as well
then it did yes I uh I would definitely
get a little bit more heat as we called
it uh in the in the South the South
didn't care for a clean cut guy who was
driving a Ford Focus they didn't think
that was very impressive uh so so
sometimes just based on who I was I
think I would get a little bit of a uh a
pushback and in Canada I mean it was
just easy it was just you know you say
the Pledge of Allegiance on the
microphone they're booing you it's it's
fantastic you know we're about to come
up here and take over you know stupid
stuff like that so
did you have to have like all this
thought out ahead of time uh before you
actually step in the ringers and do some
of it is ad-libbing or so I grew I grew
uh in the business under people who were
very much about uh improv and the idea
was okay so the way it was sat to me
which uh from a very amazing wrestler
named Ricky Morton who's part of the
rock and roll Express back in the 70s
and 80s uh probably the best tag team of
all time in my opinion but he uh he said
you know what if you plan all this stuff
out Bobby you go out there and and they
don't like it and I was like yeah it's a
good point right so a lot of times you
know you obviously know what the
promoter wants out of the match meaning
like who he wants to move on and the
story lines or whatever but
um for me I was a big fan of going out
there listening to the crowd's feedback
and then figuring out where to go from
there which is a art that is a little
bit lost in today's age because a lot of
it has moved more towards the uh stunt
and the choreographed things and it did
lose a bit of that um that rough and
tough feel that realism feel and if you
watched yeah a product now it's
beautiful and athletic but it doesn't
have uh you know something like um you
know a macho man might bring where it
was kind of chaotic and things could
break down and uh yeah there's still
some out there but it's not it's not the
main drive so for me a lot of my stuff
was improv or as we called it in the
business uh calling it on the Fly okay
and you would kind of make it up as you
go
you know when I was a kid very um my my
dad would watch awf wrestling and
um you know there were all these really
crazy performers Hulk Hogan made his
debut there as a bad guy used to like
beat up two guys at once when he still
had a full head of hair
um our favorite was the Baron von rashke
because of the you know the claw yeah
but there were all these other you know
crazy characters you know the guy Greg
gagne all these Jimmy Superfly Snuka and
things were very uh low production you
know it was uh the lighting wasn't great
um and then suddenly WWF came on and it
like totally captured the market and I
you know we'd watch it so that was like
my teen years and interestingly some of
the kids at school thought it was
completely real and they would get very
offended and angry and try to do
wrestling moves on you if you if you
told them it was fake or they had
magazines and stuff but um you know the
rest of us would watch it and a lot of
people got super super into it and I I
kind of had a hard time because it felt
like it was too glitzy you know too well
produced even though there were cool
story lines and all that and then there
were like other things that were popping
out that were again sort of like a
throwback to the older
stuff a bit more raw I I struggled to
remember what the names of those
federations were the ones that were kind
of The Underdogs when the WWF was you
had the NWA which was the massive one
which still operates today actually
um and they had a lot of different
territories I mean he had Mid-South
wrestling AWA awf
um tons and tons of places yeah and you
know it was all on TV that was the only
way we watched it back then I think I
think if you had cable which we didn't
there was more options you know
um I mean how how are besides live
obviously there's always going to be
live wrestling but is it is it mostly
streaming on different platforms how do
people find
um if they're like big wrestling fans
how do they actually find it these days
uh you know it's surprising it is still
one of the biggest and most successful
cable shows and now there's another
competitor to WWE now which is called
aew a lot of my friends uh work there
and they are on TNT just like WCW was
back in the day right now okay I would
argue that pro wrestling is one of the
only things still keeping cables pulse
going which is a crazy thing to talk
about and cable news for for well
certainly yeah my dad's never letting it
go yeah
now what was it like I mean did you get
into wrestling as like a little kid
watching these people that that's how it
started for you yeah you know I I was
the demographic as some people would say
I was poor I lived in a trailer and and
that was uh that was my entertainment
you know what I mean yeah a lot of times
I didn't have a lot to do so I would
turn on Saturday night's main event and
I go to the other kids around me and we
talk about it and I remember finding out
you know that it was scripted and all my
friends turned on we were about 10 11
years old everyone said this is stupid
and me and this is how you can tell I
love a good story as I go yeah that's so
much better they're like what are you
talking about These Guys these guys
aren't real tough guys I'm like that
doesn't matter think of all the
possibilities if you can control the
outcome you can build all these stories
and to me it opened up this idea of
creativity and storytelling and yeah I
think that's actually one of the things
that I led to my success in the business
was that I looked at it from a
storytelling perspective of and it was
never about thinking that I was a tough
guy or cool because the strange thing is
is that like we know that you know it is
theater but the people in the business
still somehow think that it that they're
they're the tough guy it's a strange
delusional world to be in to be honest
um but for me I saw the capabilities of
building and crafting very intricate
long payoff storylines and I just
thought that that was even cooler so I
never skipped the beat I never cared
um and then my friends grew out of it in
high school we did backyard wrestling
and stuff and yeah we did live shows and
sold tickets to our classmates and they
were pretty good uh compared to other
backyard stuff that you end up seeing on
YouTube or whatever but uh we uh they
grew out of it I didn't my friends went
to college I didn't and I said well
let's go let's go check out this place
down in Kaiser West Virginia and I went
and got trained by a guy named Shane
Shadows who was like a Dusty Rhodes
knockoff and okay it was it was a it was
a little sketch but you know he gave me
he gave me my start beat me up and uh
from that point on I was just kind of
doing it I was doing it every weekend
and then eventually I got some better
training up in Pittsburgh and then I
spent some time at the Ring of Honor
Dojo uh various like seminars and I
would drive out there during the week
and uh and receive training from some of
the best people in the world so at that
point it was on and uh it's all blur now
man like sitting here talking about it
it doesn't feel like that was me because
it feels so so long ago and I was such a
different uh person well the beginnings
of it but you were wrestling all the way
up to 2020 right I did have a match in
2020 March right before everything shut
down for the pandemic I was gonna ask
did is is that
part of why you retired because it was
no longer feasible you couldn't count on
it anymore so I had a lot of injuries
and I first stepped away from the
business in 2016 after I blew up my knee
a second time I actually I dislocated my
kneecap I did a lot of bone structure
damage and I needed a knee replacement
but they want I was 25 and they wouldn't
do it they wouldn't do it at 25 or 26.
and uh so I stepped away and I came back
in 2019 after like three years off and
life had changed for me so all my eggs
were in the wrestling basket up until
about 2016. and uh I started going to
college while I was on the road
wrestling I was working from hotel rooms
because I was an I.T support specialist
and I was doing online college okay and
I was doing physics and I started to
realize like I'm not dumb which you know
is counter counter to everything I had
been told all my life and what I thought
of myself yeah and I started to realize
that
um there's a chance wrestling's not
gonna work yeah and I had had about six
tryouts with WWE you know shots to be at
TV and do matches for them and they
liked a lot of what they saw from me but
they are looking for
um spectacles and a 6-1 dude that weighs
200 pounds is not exactly a spectacle
right you gotta you gotta be damn good
if you're gonna be that guy right right
so um they like me like Jimmy Superfly
Snuka right who was a little guy but he
was like crazy in the stuff that he
could do you know yes and he was very
different in that time that was when no
one was jumping off the top rope Jimmy
was jumping around cages yeah yeah so
you got to be able to bring something
and and you know I I did well and I had
respect from a lot of the people that I
wanted to get respect from and I kind of
realized that there needs to be a backup
plan and I'm so thankful that I did uh
and I can't so I came back in 2019 as a
much different person uh with bigger
aspirations than just being on WTV for a
few years so I could go to Comic Cons
and sell t-shirts so uh not that there's
anything wrong with that but I I knew I
wanted more and so when I came back to
2019 uh the fire was gone the passion
was gone the business had changed a lot
in three years surprisingly and then
covet hit
and uh the wrestling world lost its mind
and I was like what what am I doing you
know I was uh I was very conflicted
about doing the show it was like right
at the beginning of March where
everything was getting really weird and
I didn't really want to do it and I did
it and I was like why did I go and risk
you know because we didn't know what it
was at that time so I was like why did I
go exactly yeah you know I was like why
did I have to go do that and I just said
this is this is silly I'm done uh that
that part of my I needed to go back and
see if I still loved the business you
know okay it turns out that I I didn't
so
that's what led to it you know I'm very
thankful for it it has presented me with
a lot of opportunities taught me a lot
about public speaking marketing
um I also just learned how to talk to
people being on the road that was a very
important thing for me is being was that
something that was difficult for you at
first or were you always kind of a good
talker I was always kind of a good
talker because when I grew up I I wasn't
um in the popular crowd and uh you know
it was always one of the heftier kids up
until high school around 11th grade so I
kind of was a chameleon and I could fit
in okay I could make people feel very
comfortable with me uh which you know I
took pride in and then uh I just applied
that and kept it going and I also have a
Natural Curiosity I've always just been
curious about every kind of Walk of Life
and I said at many a truck stop man and
talked to truckers while they're waiting
for their showers you know and I'm
sitting yeah I'm about to go sleep in my
car they're sleeping in their truck
we're kind of doing the same thing but
we're there for different reasons I'm
making the next town for another show
and
you know I just I love talking to people
um so I think that those things really
benefited me but the wrestling uh aspect
of it was kind of done the risk was not
worth the reward and uh I kind of got my
fix for stories by starting to read
again as an adult like I took a long
break and you know I said man I can get
better stories from these books that I'm
reading well so that's that's a good
segue into talking about the sci-fi and
fantasy stuff and just like with the
wrestling
um is that something that was an
interest of yours from childhood on or
did you pick it up along along the way
so I definitely was in the generation
that got introduced to Harry Potter
right I was in second or third grade
when the first book came out and it was
a big deal it was a big deal I remember
yeah I mean it was really nothing quite
like it in my lifetime I don't think and
I read the first three books and really
loved them and then book four came out
and I was like 14 and I just kind of
lost it like I was like I just don't
care about this anymore I've kind of
outgrown this I think and then I started
reading Lord of the Rings oh because I
loved the movies and I struggled very
much with Tolkien uh in his writing
because as you can imagine going from
someone like JK Rowling who you know is
a dime a dozen as a writer in my opinion
and very readable too yeah very readable
commercial very commercial right and
then you go into something like Tolkien
who is uh just a whole nother ball game
I struggled a lot with it and then I uh
I recently found this out and one of the
reasons why I struggled is I really
found out that I'm dyslexic and I okay
never knew I I never knew and a lot of
it was me getting stuck on Words stuck
on names and not being able to continue
on so I gave up on Lord of the Rings
right after like um uh the minds I I
kind of gave up on it yeah yeah I'll
come back to it but then I read The
Hobbit
okay I love the hot until this day I
like The Hobbit more than Lord of the
Rings which is like heresy but I just
think it's such a wonderful book and I
read that and I said you know I still
really like fantasy I really do but to
me I didn't know because it was
different back then there wasn't a lot
of forums to go on there wasn't booktube
as we call the YouTube book section you
know right
um there's no book talk or whatever so I
didn't know there was other fantasy out
there so I started reading other stuff
and I read a lot of uh why a sports
dramas written by Carl Taylor he grew up
in the Seattle area and so I kind of
transitioned to a more realistic thing
because I didn't know there was other
stuff out there I literally thought it
was just Harry Potter and Lord of the
Rings I had no idea
um and to give you an idea about my
schooling that I went through you're
gonna love this they closed the school I
went to just got rid of their Library
there is no Library entirely in the
county there is no more libraries now is
that is that a primarily political thing
because usually it's not about actual
resources you know it's more these days
it's more like well we don't want the
people reading too much and then there's
this kind of
you know theoretically libertarian I
mean Libertarians are a hot mess at this
point in time but this notion like oh
let's divest all these these uh
government things that are sucking up
the you know the money the kind of
socialism is that what was going on yes
that is yes I'm from Appalachia means
spirited you know because I mean you
think about the kids who I mean who
needs the libraries the most poor kids
right who can go in check out as many
books as they want get get introduced to
things that they're not going to get
introduced to in school or their family
or whatever and and to to close I mean
it's happening here in Wisconsin too
because
um you know we're we've got this blue
City Red country red suburb kind of
dynamic going on as well yeah and then
that's kind of what happened I guess to
the school system in the county
libraries uh where I was at and uh but
you know what that's not a new attitude
towards reading because whenever I was
in school it was found upon if you sat
in the library too long you know is that
you were being lazy or whatever else it
might have been so my library didn't
have a ton of books even back then so I
didn't know that there was fantasy they
didn't have any anything they had Lord
of the Rings that was it so that's what
I read you know and uh I was a kid that
didn't have a ton growing up and my
parents were not going to go spend 15
bucks on a book or whatever it might
have been right so uh fantasy to me was
just that it was it was Harry Potter
and then it was um Lord of the Rings and
then later you know as as things got
more popular Twilight became very big
obviously uh the Divergent series Hunger
Games and I and I always just felt like
those things were as as many uh people
who think their adults think uh that's a
waste of time that's that's silly that's
kid stuff
and then of course my eyes were opened
by um a gentleman in a conductor hat
named George railroad Martin uh who uh
blew my mind when I read Game of Thrones
literally changed every preconceived
notion I had oh interesting uh that that
everything outside of Tolkien was
childish and silly and uh it took me by
surprise and that is what got me back
into reading as an adult
yeah I mean it I think for a lot of
people because of the Game of Thrones
um show got in there and mixed things up
right they don't really understand what
a massive phenomenon that's right um
that first book was and then you know he
was still writing fairly quickly back
then too and so you had you had the the
um
it was a Clash of Kings here's a second
yeah and then what was the third one uh
Storm of Swords that's right yeah
um and it was starting to slow down
Storm of Swords was paired together with
the uh fourth book because he wrote too
much and had to break them up but that
yeah Game of Thrones and my my wife is
the one who clued me into that when we
first got together so this would have
been around 2010 right she was reading
it she's like I'm buying you a copy you
got to read this and I'd read a lot of
you know fantasy and sci-fi literature
by then but you know the depth of detail
I mean some people complain about it
that Martin's plots are too complicated
I love them personally yeah exactly I
mean if you can follow a complicated
plot I mean him and Backer would be too
oh man who could certainly string
together a massive narrative the second
apocalypse the prince of nothing is
the most underrated possibly fantasy
series do you think so that's I I really
do I think the content of it gets a lot
of people to turn away from it yeah but
when people say you know I want
something that has depth to it and new
I'm like that there's really nothing
it's written so biblically like it is it
is such an impressive feat of fantasy
and he has so much inspiration from
um Cormac McCarthy that if you're a
Blood Meridian fan I almost feel like oh
the aspect Emperor uh four book sequel
Series in my opinion is fantasy's Blood
Meridian in so many ways well it
certainly this is dark right a great
ordeal yeah yeah I mean so so many uh
characters dying off I mean people
complain about Martin right yeah they
have no idea unfairly kills off they
have no idea but he does the same thing
that Martin does where he gets you
invested in the character so it hurts
when they're gone you know yes and and
you know a lot of people also put
nihilism as a label on top of A Song of
Ice and Fire but I've never agreed with
that yeah um I think George still has
heroes in his in his stories and uh I
run in the Song of Ice and Fire podcast
with my buddy Matt and we've I've read
those series
so many times and the more I read it and
the more I read like newer fantasy that
is a little bit darker I realize that
George certainly was adding a layer of
Darkness to it but there are people like
Samuel tarly who are nobodies that are
you know would be considered just like
complete losers in any other fantasy
series and Samuel tarly finds ways even
if it's accidentally to be heroic and to
be almost a knight in shining armor even
though he's wearing the black cloak of
the Night's Watch which is also kind of
a funny uh play on that and then you
read something like the second
apocalypse and Prince of nothing aspect
and you're just like oh this this is
nihilistic like this is very much uh
depressing it's fine yeah I've actually
been meaning to write a piece about
um
the the metaphor that's used in it of
the uh the Steeps you know because
you've got
um for those who are listening in and
don't know about this um you've got
these kind of nomadic Mongol type people
um who mostly get killed off
unfortunately
um and uh so we've got kanius who's
who's you know the toughest of them
basically I mean maybe there's a tougher
guy out there somewhere but he he seemed
he's the most violent of men right and
um then calhose's father and I'm
forgetting his Mo Angus I think right so
he crosses onto this the Steeps and
these are people who have like very very
deep rooted Traditions Norms they follow
them and it's it's a way of living in a
world that doesn't have any landmarks
and
um you know you just keep following the
same thing and he's introduced to this
idea that no you could do things
differently if you want to and mo Angus
is essentially seducing him and then he
goes away you know and kinnaus is left
and he and he's like oh you know I what
do I do now you know I've I've realized
it's sort of like you know nature you've
pulled back the veil and you realize
it's all Bs and now what do you do and
then Calhoun shows up who's going to be
even more powerful and they start
tracing the same lessons over and over
again and to be introduced to the fact
that you live physically in a state but
that your mental ways could be like that
as well and then you can range anywhere
you like right it sounds very
um you know liberating and all that but
when you actually have a way of life it
is nihilistic you know it's undermining
everything and yeah it is and it's also
telling you that a lot of what you
consider to be like fate or destiny is
all predetermined
um which you know
that's true too yeah our Scott Baker has
done he's I think he hasn't defended his
dissertation in in Psychology or
philosophy I can't remember philosophy
yeah yeah so he has papers and he's a
big fan of the bicameral mind theory
that uh the left and right parts of the
Mind were separate and then that is what
for instance The Iliad was based off of
is like that people used to hear these
voices in their head and it was actually
the other side of their brain and
there's a lot more to it uh but he plays
with that in the series which is a wild
thing to do uh it's just really really
adventurous uh in in my opinion kind of
a uh uh a big risk to put those type of
things in a fantasy series if you did it
today I don't think it would get
published uh which was some of his
issues with his sequel series he he
couldn't find an editor he couldn't find
a publisher that one to work with him
the last book he published the Unholy
console which is one of the biggest
mind-blowing series finales ever
um was unedited there's a lot of
spellings I didn't realize that he
didn't have any editors for the last two
books and that's why
you know you've read it but when you get
to book three of that there's all that
there's a head on a poll behind you and
all the second person narrative stuff
like you can tell the the restrictor
plate came off and it was just raw
backer and uh man what what a uh series
that is at least trying to do something
more and different with the genre so
yeah man I I really hope that he I mean
he's pledged that he's going to finish
it out with some some additional books
but I mean there's no sign of that
happening I don't like
um leaving the story in the Dismal
ending place that it is which I won't
say anything about because uh I don't
want to do spoilers but I I that's
actually a good segue into something
else that I was going to ask you about
so in your um YouTube channel the
fantasy Network you have two very
different attitudes about spoilers on
the one hand you have no spoiler book
reviews which I I you know I get the
idea behind that but I'd like to hear
you say more about that in a minute and
then you have
um I forget exactly how you build it and
I think it's in the live section you
have stuff where you say we're gonna
give you spoilers right here and it's um
it's not the discussions it's not just
along the way it's that's the theme
right so what was the uh was it because
you weren't giving spoilers in the book
reviews that you're like well I want to
do spoilers somewhere else or okay yes
so uh no spoiler book review is a very
difficult thing it is a skill to be able
to talk about a book in some sort of
meaningful non just surface level way
and you know if you look at my old
videos from almost four years ago I
don't know if I did a great job back
then but I do believe that I've done a
pretty good job lately and the reason be
because of the reason why I wanted to do
this and the whole because behind it was
when I was getting back into reading I
faced the same problem as I did when I
finished Tolkien and I I finished George
R Martin's works and then I started
reading a little bit of his sci-fi and
then the short stories that he wrote and
I'm like okay I love this guy but
there's got to be more out there but
when you walk into a Barnes Noble and
you haven't read in 10 years yeah you
look at all those books and it's just
like Netflix you go 90 of this might be
bad like there's a 90 chance a lot of
this is schlock and garbage right how do
you end with books it's a bigger time
investment so when you walk into the
store you know you're you're spending
your hard-earned money you're going to
spend your time reading a book and if
you get a stinker that might be the last
book you ever read you might say you
know what there aren't that many good
books out there so my my way of finding
out that people are talking about the
stuff on YouTube was looking for more
and I saw people there's a really big
booktuber named Daniel Green who has
done all types of fantasy videos and I
said that is a a service I hate to put
it like that but it's a service that
that is very helpful to to new aspiring
readers are getting back into reading at
all so I said this this is what I want
to do I want to do spoiler-free reviews
and try to help curate like what people
may like about this book look so it's
not just about what I like but it's
about what a book is trying to say what
it's trying to do maybe some of the
tropes that it might include and then
like you know what people are saying
about it's actually one of the things I
love about your videos like whenever you
cover it you always read critics reviews
like people who gave it maybe five times
and people give it one star and you kind
of give your take like well I don't know
if that's earned or whatever it might be
I actually love that about your videos
and I've never went quite that far but I
do listen to the discussion around Books
Okay so I'm like you know if you're not
into this this book does have that and
you should be aware of it so I wanted to
help other people get get going and then
there's books that you just have to talk
spoilers about because they're so darn
interesting and is the second apocalypse
is one of those series that you have to
sit down with someone and say can you
believe this happened like this is
insane and then there are also books
that need explanation I am reading
through book of the new Sun by Gene wolf
currently I'm in book two okay let me
tell you what I'm like okay
about everything that Gene wolf writes
oh my gosh I mean that's somebody that
you could do hours on just half of a
book right so there are books that
deserve an elevated discussion without
those restrictions that I think you can
the people who uh who went and
experience the book would maybe get
something more out of it so I don't do
it with every book but there are times
where I feel like it's necessary to do a
little bit more
well that makes a lot of sense and
actually there was something about
um
my videos that uh
not not these
um speculative fiction ones but just the
ones that I do in front of my chalkboard
that I was going to say is similar to
what you're doing with these
um book reviews
so you mentioned not making it just
about what you like about the book but
thinking about what other people who
haven't read the book
would want to know about it and that's
sort of what I do when I like core
concept videos you know I'm doing a
whole set on Aristotle's Poetics now and
I I think to myself before I shoot these
you know so I'm going to talk about this
and this and this and this but what is
it that my listeners or viewers are on
are likely to get confused about or will
need to know more about what are they
going to be curious about or what are
they what are the areas where they're
going to be like what the hell is this
crap you know and so I try to as best as
I can to keep that in mind as I'm
talking in my empty room you know to the
camera as if it's a a live person
that's such that's the hardest thing
about YouTube is just yelling at a
camera you're like what am I doing
I suppose too yeah I mean you come from
a long background of automatically
having an audience right you can't rest
I mean you can't wrestle on your own
just two guys you know uh knocking stuff
over in the living room but yeah you
can't do wrestling without uh a crowd
yeah um and I had a similar kind of
thing when I first started you know I
was always just shooting videos in the
classroom I would plunk the camera down
and just let it run or I would go
somewhere give a talk and and video
record it and you know you've got that
automatic rapport with well it's not
automatic but at least after you've been
doing it for a while it's pretty easy to
get people to listen to you
um but doing it to an empty classroom
that's what I did first and I'd go in
when nobody was in a classroom and shoot
some some videos from my students that I
knew it was on stuff they needed and
then eventually we you know got a
chalkboard at home and the only people
there were the dogs and cats watching me
they don't care about philosophy the
cats will judge you you got to be
careful for the cats man yeah mine are
brutal
so
um
did it take you a while to get
comfortable on camera just talking yeah
I did it took a while because what did
you do that to make it easier for
yourself did you like picture people
there or I I said slow down
because yeah if you go back and watch my
very first video it's uh is gay is a
song by some fire worth reading even
though Game of Thrones show ending
sucked and it's just me for eight
minutes going 100 miles an hour going
the
bro Breeze you know it's gonna be okay
and I decided to pretend uh that I was
talking to someone that I like I would
whenever I was on the road or whatnot oh
yes there's a there's a very weird
element of that where no one is talking
back to you uh but I may I even in my
video sometimes I'll pause as if I'm
waiting like you know I'll be like you
know what I mean and I'll just sit and
my idea is I'm hoping that that draws
the viewer in to feel like they can have
a conversation with me and then maybe
drop a comment and then me and them can
talk
you know yeah I I just I try my best to
to make sure that people feel like
they're a part of the video and that's
why I respond to every single comment I
get on my book Channel every single one
um
so I'm going to ask you something about
like uh uh Channel comments then and I
think I probably have a different
practice and and maybe a different
mindset about this I'm not as welcoming
now if somebody has a nice comment I
will answer it and you know I'll even uh
you know like if it's a longer comment
but it's on point I'll I'll address it
at length right
but if somebody's a jerk then I
sometimes respond and I'll say okay
that's that's off base or something like
that you might want to reconsider that
and sometimes I just remove it and block
them like if somebody's being just a
troll and I found that so I started
doing that on videos but I also started
doing it in amas people would pop in and
you know act like jerks and then I I
just click and and they're gone and then
I found that over time
um even though there are like calls
every once in a while on on like 4chan
let's get Sadler you know he's a jerk
you know
um pilot on him oh yeah yeah I went I
went through a period so this is a bit
of a we'll come back to the question
that I've got for you I went through a
period where I was the darling of 4chan
for a while the lit people because I was
doing cool stuff you know on Hegel and
you know I know what I'm talking about
unlike almost all of them and most of
the people that they they like and uh
and then you know
um they're they're a very fickle crowd
you know and and I think in part because
insecurities and their lives kind of
suck and stuff like that for the most
part
so um I don't remember exactly what
thing it was but they decided that I was
a bad guy you know and there were still
a few Defenders but most of them would
be like he's a fraud he's a fake you
know and a lot of the comments show like
they don't understand how things
actually work like they would say well
he's not a real Professor he's just an
adjunct not knowing anything about like
how the academic job market works or you
know I actually left I left a full-time
job I would love to go marry my wife and
then I became an adjunct and once you're
on their their you know crap list you're
on it you know they will never stop
talking about you in in their forums and
so anyway they would they would try to
pop over the channel and
um now that doesn't happen much I mean I
still get a few jerks every once in a
while but it's not like it was early on
where you know you say something then
people would just come out of the
woodwork right so I'm curious do you you
know aggressively block and I do this in
all my social media I do it in Twitter I
do it in Facebook if somebody's my
viewpoint so I'll I'll I'll ask in just
a minute but my viewpoint is my social
media and in YouTube is like my front
porch if you want to come on and have a
conversation cool but you wouldn't go on
to somebody else's front porch and then
start blathering about stuff and and you
know act like a jerk and not expect for
them to kick you off the porch you know
and if I kick them out of my thing I'm
not you know they're all like oh
censorship you know freedom of speech
you can go you know say your stuff in
the million other YouTube channels if
you want to or on somebody else's
Twitter thing so I don't I don't feel as
if I'm like you know closing down debate
or anything I'm just saying that's not
going to happen here you know so what
what do you do and and why do you do it
well if it's nonsense and has nothing to
do with the topic because I have had
that yeah I even had old wrestling fans
that would come and you know just bring
bring up stupid things and this and that
you know and I don't have I don't have
much time for that okay but if someone
disagrees with a review of mine which I
I that happens quite often actually yeah
um
I I have found that a lot of the times
you can just like why do you feel that
way or this is why I feel this way and
that has led to very productive
conversations however there are a subset
of people who want to disagree with you
and want you to know that because they
think you are incorrect in your opinion
that you are morally awful and I don't
agree with that so yeah I I if it has
anything to do with like personal stuff
I immediately banned them like I don't
even have a question about it
um but I have tried to
extend the olive branch and you know a
good good example of this
is that uh I have a friend and he used
to do book content but now he does short
comedy skits and he's blowing up on
YouTube it's crazy uh actually the guy
who plays Dwight on the office has been
tweeting his videos out oh nice which is
really cool right and I left a comment
on one of his older videos back in the
day before it went viral and I said
something about time anxiety which is
the uh anxiety of feeling like you need
to be productive 100 of the time okay
not feeling okay watching a movie
because you're like that's an hour and a
half and then like halfway through you
turn it off because you feel guilty and
I suffered from this in the pandemic
because of the extra time I had where I
couldn't go to the gym or Jiu Jitsu
anymore right and I was like man this is
like a real thing like I can't enjoy
things right now because I feel like I'm
wasting my time with everything and I I
had mentioned in the comment that I
uh felt guilty reading fantasy books and
sci-fi and reading in general and a
person had a commented just like a year
and a half later they commented because
the video blew up and they said you know
you should feel bad there's nothing
there's nothing useful about reading
fiction
and I of course wanted to be like hey
you're an idiot uh how close-minded
could you be and I said you know what
I'm gonna show I'm gonna give them my
take and I did and I went back and forth
about 10 comments and that person said
I'm gonna go pick up farseer by Robin
Hobb and I was like let's go oh that's
very cool however I've also tried that
before and it's not worked and then it's
led to further harassment unfortunately
and so it you kind of have to feel it
out I think
um I would say I'm a bit probably about
50 50 100 of the time if it's anything
personal
um I did have one person recently I
mentioned how I love tahanu by Ursula K
Le Guin yeah I think it's a beautiful
book I think it is uh Ursula K Le Guin
maturing as a writer taking 20 years
away from further Shore to write to hanu
and it is a powerful angry feminist work
that is neither preachy uh nor like
cheesy in any way but it's very very
emotional and well thought out and uh I
think valid in its anger towards society
and I said that in a wrap-up that's all
I said I just said this is a feminist
book that has a lot to say and I think
Ursula Kayla wins best fantasy work and
they said oh feminist like not I'll
never read that way to get me to never
read that book and I was just like okay
okay so anything that's feminist at all
is bad apparently and with that person
yeah there's no getting through to them
so they they got blocked they got the
old band Hammer but
um you know I don't know I try to be
reasonable if I can
um especially when it comes to book
disputes because I don't know if you
know this but some people get really mad
if you don't like their favorite book oh
I know they can get really upset and you
could you could like the author and say
you know I like all their other stuff I
just don't particularly care for this
book and you're you know or you can say
one negative thing and 100 positive
things and they focus on the negative
that is just a symptom of being online
you know that that happens as well in in
philosophy
um I mean probably not to the extent
that it does with
fiction but you do get people who are
real partisans you know or or another
example
um they're they're upset because I don't
do content on you know some particular
thinker and if you actually look at like
the stuff that I've covered it's sort of
like a spectrogram you know like there's
a couple little lines here and there but
most of it's blank right so people will
be like why haven't you done videos on
Spinoza well I haven't gotten to them
you know and there's like 10 other
people ahead on the list that I'd rather
do because I and I recognize he's an
important philosopher and people do get
into them but I'm not into him you know
and I don't have to be into everybody
and it's even more the case with like
anything that's not Western philosophy
people are like why aren't you doing
Arabic philosophy why aren't you talking
about uh Indian philosophy or Chinese
philosophy and I'll be like well first
of all I don't read Arabic or classical
Chinese
well I mean I couldn't I could like
opine about you know these translations
that I've read but but I kind of like to
know what I'm talking about you know
that's where you're online yeah and then
and then you know I'm not a specialist
um you know I I teach some Chinese
philosophy and I like reading it in
Translation but there's better people
out there who could be doing that you
know there's like a division of labor
and and I I think that's I mean with
fiction you know we've got just a a
massively wider field than philosophy
you know I don't know it's probably like
a hundred times as wide right so there's
no way you can talk about everybody uh
you're always going to be leaving
somebody out you know yeah I mean in
reading it's the ever-growing TBR I want
to read a million things but I found out
that I can only read so many books in a
year and especially with
you know I don't want to consume books I
want to read them thoroughly okay and I
want to explain that distinction because
I think that might be something that
listeners could benefit oh my friend
um so with YouTube or what we call
booktube is what everyone just calls it
who's in the book sphere yeah um there
is a lot of different versions of what
people do there's no set criteria to be
part of what we call booktube but one of
the things that does seem to be
congruent along among many channels is
that you know people are trying to read
the most books they can per month and
and the number of books is almost a
badge of honor people post their
statistics which I'm fine with I get it
and that's a motivator for a lot of
people so I'm fine anything that gets
people reading I'm not hating
um but I realize very quickly as I was
Finding like my voice and what I wanted
to do with my Channel that I could not
Chase those numbers like I don't want to
read 20 books in a month I actually I
actively don't want to do that and
people do because as audio books or
maybe responsibilities a little bit more
relaxed or whatever it might be
um but you know I do a lot of stuff like
I I have a lot of stuff I do obviously
you know but making any type of content
or media takes a lot of time and I work
out almost every day I go to jiu jitsu
I'm a husband and I have a job that's
I'm very fortunate for but is you know
can be demanding as well so yeah for me
you know I like reading about two to
four books a month now sometimes I read
a lot more than that there are times
where I read seven or eight books but
they're very short
um and you know I don't want to just
think about plot beats but I want to
think about themes I want to think about
especially in fantasy because someone
who is well read in fantasy or trying to
be I want to have an idea of the Canon
of the genre of of what came before
right like knowing that Jean wolf was
inspired by Jack Vance who was inspired
by dunsany uh in the dying Earth and
then like uh nif the lean which is a
book I don't know if anybody knows about
Michael Shea uh who ended up getting
permission from Jack Vance to write a
book inside of the dying Earth world
oh one printing ever one printing ever
which is crazy and not like one book but
like he only got it printed once and
that was it yeah yeah I own a copy I
should show it to you sometime it's very
cool very yellow but those are the
things I'm interested in I'm interested
in how we got here with Science Fiction
and Fantasy and then also the time you
know I books can change your life I've
had books that have had profound
experiences or impacts on me and I don't
know if you get that at listening to an
audiobook at 3x speed I just don't know
if that can really happen you know
that's yeah that's another interesting
uh thing uh you know people will tell me
that they watch my videos at
um anywhere from 1.25 to two speed and
I'm like that's a terrible idea you know
I mean I'm explaining something that you
probably you probably should slow it
down and let it sink in you know because
I know what I'm doing because I've been
doing this 20 years you know but if
you're like watching a video where I'm
talking about Aristotle or God forbid
Hegel you know going through hegel's
phenomenology you really gotta pause it
and let it sink in and what do they call
these speed runs yeah so speed runs
strike me as being totally
counterproductive because they give you
the sense that you've like learned
something and that like maybe some of it
stick but it's very unlikely that it
will I mean there might be some people
out there who can I think if you can
train it I think that it is I think it's
something you can adapt to and one thing
that is interesting and because
audiobooks are always a big Topic in
Reading circles and stuff but one of the
reasons why people do have trouble with
audiobooks is that narration of
audiobooks is very slow and your your
brain is used to a more conversation
tone like we are our speed and your
brain is essentially losing track of the
audiobook because your brain can handle
more information and it's like okay we
got this okay what else can we think
about so bumping up an audiobook to like
a 1.1 to a one point even three has been
shown to have larger amounts of
attention because your brain is at has
to pay attention more and it simulates
conversation which I think is
fascinating I think that could work for
fiction
uh not so much lectures on Eagle well I
used to I used to listen to and bet this
is dating me I used to listen to books
on CD right I'd go to the library oh
yeah and and get the the CD of something
out or LibriVox right and then I'd burn
it onto a CD and then I had to take
these long drives and I would I would
listen to stuff and I found that you
know and so I'm somebody who studies
philosophy and I'm listening to books
that I've already read many times I
cannot follow Rene Descartes meditations
in the LibriVox version just listening
to it in my car because you know I'm
looking around at stuff and idle
thoughts and then you know it's like
five minutes and I'm like oh crap what
did I just hear right whereas if it's
the like I listen to All of Homer's
Odyssey
um one set of drives going back and
forth from my job at Indiana State
Prison which was an hour commute each
each way
um and that was no problem and as a
matter of fact one of the things I'd be
curious to get your take on this
I found that there were there were
aspects of the work that I
paid more attention to maybe or or
realized better when I listened to it
that I'd missed when I'd read it and I
think vice versa too there's probably
you're probably going to miss some
things that are reading when it would
get you do you have that experience when
you're listening okay for sure and my
retention is worse when I listen to
audiobooks and and you know the one
thing about it is is fiction non-fiction
whatever it might be book to book is a
totally different ask of the reader
right I can listen to a Dresden Files
book on audio and get most of it I mean
it is a Noir fantasy detective novel
they're about 300 pages long and and
they're fun but they're not
they're not crazy uh they're not Moby
Dick right okay uh blood Murray oh yeah
yeah Blood Meridian I tried to do that
on audio and I was trying to do my you
know I read about 50 pages a day of a
book sometimes 100 if I'm if I'm really
open and free for the day
um but Blood Meridian I was reading it
10 pages a day and I think it took me 50
days and I had tried some on audio to
kind of speed up my pace and I was like
I can't do this I can't if I really want
to get what this book is trying to tell
me I don't think that I can do that in
fact I would say the Blood Meridian has
to be read multiple times to really
start to understand what what in the
world McCarthy was going for there oh
yeah and that's all another thing some
books I think like for instance I think
the second apocalypse Prince of nothing
should be read multiple times I think
there's just so much to latch on to
there
um I would agree with you but I think
that is also a hard sell to readers and
I think for two reasons one is that I
mean they use the term slog in there and
the reading is a slog because there's
just so much going on but it's also
um I think for a lot of readers
depressing
yes it took a lot out of me reading
those books and I'm someone who has a
high tolerance for depressing things
it's kind of my my jam uh I mean there
are a lot of really cool things in it
World building's crazy good yeah and the
character development you know uh
akmanian changes significantly
especially in relation to his daughter
oh
um
um becoming you know like the really
like he's almost like the right hand of
the consult and so right right yeah
kelhus he he changes significantly
I mean she she might have the biggest
growth of everyone she goes from a
prostitute to
the uh the the [__] of the Kingdom I
think is what they refer to her as or
something it's it's something awful but
also a policy decider yeah big big
policy keeping the family together
keeping the capital together I mean this
is uh
some major stuff so yeah you know and
that's the thing is like you might read
through something or listen let's say
listen to something for instance and you
might be able to pick up on the plot
beats and the characterization and then
you read it and then you see all of this
other like the Thematic stuff coming out
so right pull that out of a book you
know and that's why when people tell me
like I read that book and I thought it
was trash or you know I can't understand
why anyone likes this book and I said
well that's very close-minded of you
because there is so much to latch on to
in each individual series or story or
whatever you're doing yeah uh that it's
never impossible to imagine someone
liking something uh that to me is very
ignorant like
I hear reviewers say that all the time
and I I hate it which in topic um still
within the realm of books you mentioned
that some books have changed your life
uh you talked about tolstoya's death of
even Ilitch and some of the other short
stories and that's some some really good
existentialist stuff what are some of
the other books that have that you would
say like had that sort of impact on you
that changed your your life changed your
mindset about things
um I man that that's a great question I
would say the death of even ilyitch
might have been the most impactful book
I've ever read oh interesting uh like
and it was also recent so there's a
little bit of recency bias in there but
in the same vein an author who had had
to have read that story and then wrote
his own book which was never famous
until after he died he was destroyed in
the uh the Press being called a you know
journeyman pros and all this other stuff
uh and his name is John E Williams and
he wrote Augustus butcher's Crossing and
the book that I'm talking about which is
Stoner okay donor has nothing to do with
uh ingesting any sort of medicinal or
recreational plants but which I was
disappointed to find out but uh he is a
professor
and he is middle of the road
and he just exists and then he dies and
it tells you everything that's going to
happen in the story on the first page
and you live his life as a professor and
it is meant to be the antithesis to The
Great Gatsby he is he is not flaunting
anything he is not extravagant he is
actually extremely plain and passive and
I have never never read a book
that was so boring but yet so gripping
and enticing to read I could not put it
down there's no reason this book should
be this good and it came very popular
after he had passed away many years
later and people found it and they said
this is a this is a classic like this
this is something that you know people
should be reading and it takes place in
the World War II era uh which which I
I'm kind of fond of in fiction whenever
I read uh stuff that is set in a
different time period I usually like
that that period but Stoner by John
Williams could be the greatest book I've
ever read
um and I would highly recommend it to
you it's only 200 Pages the audiobook is
free on Audible and it's fantastic and
it is one you can do on Audible
um he has such perfect prose it is
neither pretentious or or plain he just
knows exactly the words and where to put
them to say things that in plain
language rock you to your core and you
know you were in Academia I think you
might even get a little more out of it I
have two friends that are teachers one's
a high school teacher one's a professor
yeah and they came back to me and said
maybe the best book I've ever read but
hit way too close to home they said oh
my gosh like what if I I gotta do
something with my life like this was too
much of a mirror for me and um
very profound very profound I think that
that had a big impact on me and thinking
about uh the dangers of living a passive
life in the hopes of making things
easier for everyone else and you know
not fighting the good fight
um and then other books that have really
changed me I would say Robin Hobbs Realm
of the elderling series which follows
Fitz chivalry farcier through his
lifespan
um of being a royal bastard and
basically being used by the throne his
entire life and the thing that I took
away from Realm of the oldings by Robin
Hobb and she's a wonderful author
beautiful prose
um is that she was able to accomplish
something because the series is so long
16 books long goes over decades she was
able to really start to inspect
generational trauma and guilt and
I have never had like a light bulb flip
on reading a book so much as me and when
you look around at people who you love
call friends or family and you realize
that they have done wrong by you and you
still love the person but you have to
deal with that and you have to deal with
the guilt of maybe things that you've
done wrong to people that you love Yeah
and and how that transcends in your life
and things that affected you when you
were 15 are still coming back to you
when you're 45 and uh just really really
intimate writing that I I think is
gorgeous and uh no easy answers in that
series either and uh the other series
that has changed me in a profound way
would be the milazzin series by Stephen
Erickson archaeologist Anthropologist uh
one of the most intelligent men I've
ever met I've met him and I've
interviewed him and I've had multiple
chats with him been out to dinner with
him uh but I had read the series first
so it wasn't like I got you know I got
the hook up with him and then I like oh
I'll read your books I'll love them no I
I sought him out because especially in
2016 and 2020 we all know that it became
a lot harder to reconcile differences of
a political nature or from a belief
standpoint right and malazin book of the
Fallen
our ten tails in this Blazin Universe
with the through line plot but it's each
book has like a different cast with a
couple reoccurring characters there's
nothing really quite like it in fantasy
but he goes into the idea of absolution
and of mercy and compassion
unlike any other author I've ever read
in any genre and he really tests the
bounds of compassion okay and there's a
quote he has uh in the series that has
stuck with me and I'm paraphrasing but
essentially is that uh
there's a moment where someone is being
absolved and no one thinks that this
group of people should be absolved and
the basically the person who's doing the
absolving says this is compassion
compassion and empathy uh should be
given an abundance and not as a gift
it should be given unconditionally
because if you are no longer doing it if
you're only doing it for people who
deserve it then it's no longer
compassion it is it is simply a
transactional thing it is gifts no one
expects you not to be empathetic towards
your friends but the people who you
disagree with so with all that fire and
I know because I'm like that
um it made me take myself out of my
shoes
and put me in in the other person's
shoes and he plays a lot with
perspective about because it's about the
Malaysian Empire which we all know
colonialism is bad right but then he
looks at the other side of colonialism
without like excusing it but like it's
bad but it also did help in this
circumstance and how do we reconcile
these two things and who are we supposed
to root for in this right right it's
really fascinating stuff and I think it
does a beautiful job of reintegration
which Stephen Donaldson talks about in
an interview about why fantasy is so
important and he talks about basically
being able to experience uh traumas or
other events in our lives or you know
stepping in someone else's shoe from a
fantasy secondary World perspective and
then when you leave that world and come
back to reality you can you can
reintegrate with the environment in
which you live and that is one of the
most powerful things that fantasy can do
and I can't think of a better fantasy
series than milazin uh at doing that so
that's really cool because that's that's
the one that I'm finishing up the year
with hi how many people have recommended
that oh in the voting you mean I voted
and I said hey everyone in my Discord
because they all watch you and I'm like
you guys should all go vote on this and
vote for malaza because wow so you
rigged the vote essentially I mean it's
great you know I lobbied I said hey if
you're so inclined this guy has made
amazing stuff for second Apocalypse in
Ursula K Le Guin I was like we'd all
love to see him do Stephen Erickson so
yeah
I I have to say
um
so I you know I've been doing this
voting thing now for I don't know three
four years where I reserve
um out of 12 slots I reserve three for
like uh whatever we're gonna call them
fan favorites
I have not had a bad recommendation yet
where
you know people were like you gotta read
this one and they actually voted on it
and then I read it and I was like yeah
just not very good but I have in the
series uh early on I I originally I did
it so it was like an excuse to go back
and read the books and series that I
liked in my teens and 20s and stuff like
that and I did go through
um a series that I just absolutely loved
as a teenager and young college student
uh Michael morcox Cornelius Chronicles
and they did not hold up you know I mean
there was oh no okay but they weren't
they weren't great you know I just read
my first more [__] book I read Elric of
nibiday well you got all different stuff
right you got the the Dark Fantasy with
with uh Elric and there's another guy
who I can't remember his name but he's
another champion or something like that
the Eternal Champion right well the
Eternal Champion is all these guys okay
it's like a connected Universe yeah well
they're all avatars of the Eternal
Champion so Elric is an eternal Champion
Jerry Cornelius is an eternal Champion
but there's another guy who's who's got
some Celtic name who also fights against
you know chaos and stuff like that and
those are good I like I like that stuff
and the the Cornelius Chronicles it was
about like you know the whole world
cracking apart in the 60s and 70s and
all this connection with rock and roll
and I used to like listen to it while
you know playing Van Halen in the
background and and you know uh sipping
sodas and all that and um and then you
know in college like drinking and
reading it at the same time and it's all
it's all like little Snippets of stuff
so it's very imaginative but it just
didn't make it for me anymore
um somehow I I feel like I outgrew it
but but that's not the case with so many
other things I mean I had the humbling
experience of going back to a series
that I think I really understand and
then being like holy crap did I misread
this before you know the best that's the
best feeling in the world because you're
like man these These Old favorites don't
have something for me oh yeah and books
read us they read us just as much as we
read them
um yeah if I had read malazin five years
ago I would have been like this is trash
Oh I would have hated it yeah because
it's not your typical like multiple POV
uh like a tad Williams or George R
Martin I mean it is very different it is
very very different and you have to be
willing to meet the cast halfway and
engage with the story and a lot you know
you're gonna have to
um be okay with hopping around a lot
okay and I think Erickson does the best
characterization it's very indirect and
it's very distanced but I I actually
love it he can get me to care about a
character in like two paragraphs and
also there's the melazza Marines which
are directly inspired from black company
which I love black Company by Glenn cook
like that book's on the ground grunt you
know Glenn cook was the first guy to
instead of going with the hero on the
White Horse he went with the grunts that
were like leading the back of the charge
you know and I thought when was he doing
that in 1980 or 82. I can't remember
which a year but because because I I
mean I'd also say somebody else who's
doing that is uh Gordon Dixon with the
door size stuff although they are Elite
troops right yeah but but yeah I mean
like they can be a private or somebody
like that yeah that no that that's
actually a very very good point and and
I would say even Glenn Cook's people
they're they're powerful but it's just
that they are pawns on the chessboard
for these Gods oh okay so it just uh I
mean really Wacky World building a black
company as well which melizon
um has dinosaurs with swords for arms
which sounds ridiculous but it's like
the most metal thing I've ever read in
my life and it's so cool like it's so
cool dinosaurs eat though you know I
mean they can't who knows dude but they
run around they got these blades for
arms and P and they they're huge I mean
as you can tell so the interesting thing
about malazin is that it was a tabletop
game between him and his best friend Ian
C esselmon who has published melizon
Universe books they're not a part of the
series but they're like extended
Universe stuff and they gained a lot of
what's in the books and some of the big
events and deaths that happened were
made on a coin flip or a dice roll wow
isn't that crazy that is yeah yeah the
World building is excellent there's no
patriarchy built in which is another
very unique thing about milaz and coming
into the late 90s uh and it was written
in early 90s and late 80s but um you
know every story has a patriarchy every
single story not mallazzin and it's not
like oh look there is no patriarchy it
just is like there's female adjuncts
there's uh Empress like no one's really
paying attention to gender and it's a
really fascinating uh piece of fantasy
in like the broad spectrum of like what
was going on at the time it was very
unique I mean somebody else who I think
also does that is um chera CJ chaira and
I've never I've haven't read them now I
haven't read her fantasy stuff but um
she's extremely prolific but the
alliance Union Universe where Earth has
colonized the solar system and then you
know gone out into the far stars and
then figured out how to do faster than
light travel and it's a you know there's
all these interesting you know
conjectures about Humanity I mean it's
it's a good ways into the future so very
Dynamic female characters there
sometimes is something like an old boys
club but a lot of these female spacers
will kick your teeth in if you try to
you know try to try to harass them or
stuff like that and
um you know I going back to like if if I
had read her when I was younger I think
I would have found the incredible depth
of detail just too boring you know and
uh now it's you know you read the stuff
and you're like wow and I also wanted to
bring her up in relation to the trauma
stuff I mean that's that's a theme that
she really handles well and not in a
sort of um cookie cutter everybody's got
trauma way it's like this character and
what happened to their family or this
character and how they got left behind
by their their ship you know and
figuring out how to fit fit yourself in
um which is a kind of a young adult
theme but she's not doing it in young
adult stuff like the coming of age where
where do I fit right right and there
aren't any what do they call them where
where like the characters the the one
and true king
um like the chosen one yeah that's It
The Chosen One Trope she doesn't have
chosen one the most worn out Trope of
all time
yes very much so no one can just be
somebody like the Star Wars sequels like
yeah yeah they almost did it they almost
did something cool and then they made
her Skywalker
yeah I you know this will probably be
controversial you may disagree with me
on this but I don't think Star Wars is
very good I don't like Star Wars at all
okay here's my struggle I can't say that
on my channel because my mom watches and
my mom doesn't understand nerd stuff so
every Christmas she buys me Star Wars
stuff and I have to pretend to like it I
mean when you were a kid did you like it
no I always hated something interesting
I mean you know but we were crazy about
it and you know like when it first came
out in the theater you know you go there
and it's like amazing and then you have
the action figures and you know like I I
had three action figures two of which
were Darth Vader's
because I I had you know we we weren't
rich but we weren't we weren't uh poor
uh but my parents were very frugal and
so they they didn't go in for all this
faddish stuff like the kids next door
did who had like you know the Millennium
Falcon and all these Troopers and stuff
like that so we were we would go to the
store and every once in a while my mom
would be like you can pick out a toy you
know each one of you
um so I got a Darth Vader action figure
and then the next week
um we had a spelling bee and I won the
spelling bee and the prize was uh Darth
Vader figure so now I got two Darth
Vaders you know what do you do playing
with them right yeah well they fight
each other yeah and and then I I
somewhere along the line picked up an
Obi-Wan Kenobi one so now at least they
could fight you know legitimately but
Obi-Wan I always lost because it was two
Darth Vaders against one Obi-Wan you
know and that was it that's all I had my
sister got Princess Leia uh we didn't
have a Luke or Han Solo
but you know we're all Gaga about it and
there were comic books and all sorts of
cool stuff lunch boxes and you know
later on down the line
um when I had my own kids
um and they'd remastered the original
Three you know and and the prequels
would come out and they all kind of
sucked they weren't very good
um even though there was a big lead up
to it but you know I was like well we'll
watch the original Three and my kids
didn't like it and
um I was watching and I was like man I I
remember this being a very different
kind of set of movies I didn't remember
Luke being so whiny all he does is
complain you know what the hell kind of
hero is this and I guess I was like I
guess it was the 70s you know
um and then Han Solo's is just you know
a jerk basically you know
um and I I couldn't find much that I
enjoyed about him and so when the new
um the later ones you know seven eight
nine came out I was like I'm not not not
going to bother yeah well you didn't
miss much uh they were pretty they
looked really cool
um
strangely enough my job at the time uh
rented out the theater for the third one
so I felt like I should go watch the
first two and that's the reason why I
ended up watching them and to be fair as
a theater experience just like from
visual audio it was very nice right yeah
the the story didn't make much sense
um I've never been impressed by Star
Wars I I thought I think some of the
World building stuff is really neat and
there's a lot of potential there but it
extended Universe stuff is yeah like
Timothy Zahn has a book uh yeah heir of
the Empire or something like that and
it's supposed to go into the thrawn
stuff
when I hear people talk about it I go
man I really want to get into that but
then they're like you have to read these
six books they all suck they're not
canon and then you got to read these
Canon things and then you can read and
I'm like I'm done I'm out yeah I'm not
doing this
that reminds me of something
um there was a book by Alan Dean Foster
called Splinter the Mind's Eye yeah
it was actually supposed to be like the
sequel not Empire Strikes Back
and because they didn't think they did
they didn't know that Star Wars was
actually going to take off and make
money so they had to have something that
could be
low budget with easy sets so it's mostly
set in these caves
um and in it interestingly enough
um Luke and Leah are on this planet and
Darth Vader pursues them and uh he beats
Luke and then Leia picks up the
lightsaber and ends up cutting off Darth
Vader's arm and knocking him down like
an endless well kind of Chasm thing
um and so that came out like a year
after Star Wars and I was like wow
that's that's a cool wrap up for this
right and then Empire Strikes Back came
out and I was like what the hell is
going on here I was so confused they
pulled the old bait and switch with you
then yeah well it and if uh if Star Wars
hadn't made a ton of money that was
going to be what how they were going to
wrap the whole thing up you know two
movie thing yeah that sounds better yeah
that that's gonna that's gonna get me
some uh some hate mail possibly but yeah
I don't know I'm with you I'm thank God
there's somebody else who doesn't like
Star Wars I always say I wish I loved it
it because there's I love buying swag
and merchandise like I am definitely a
consumerist when it comes to these type
of things and I'm like there's no end to
the Star Wars stuff that you could buy I
know because my mom buys me something
every year and it's brand new and I'm
like what is this but all the series I
there are no uh Ursula Kayla Gwynn
figurines or t-shirts well it's it's
there have been a couple attempts to
adapt Earthsea and they're all total
dismal failures even Ghibli studio
ghibli's version of Earth that means
that she was not happy about that
um nor should she have been yeah it's
interesting because I I taught a class
on Earthsea at Milwaukee Institute of
Art and Design going through all six
books you know and a lot of the students
had watched the Ghibli thing beforehand
because they're all into anime you know
and again so confused because it
diverges from the plot so much you know
those books are so interesting
um you know I I have a friend who uh
runs a YouTube channel and she's very
successful and she read Earthsea and
she's like you know I just don't it
feels like a kids book kind of and I was
like well the first one kind of did US
yeah but it grows with its audience
which is something that people laud
praise for Rawling doing in Harry Potter
and I'm like well Ursula Kate Le Guin
did it first because her characters
legitimately grow up and the books are
written for the level of where the
characters are like Tejano is nothing
yeah like where's diversity but it's in
the same series it's so impressive you
know and that's the longest one in the
series and I think tahanu is maybe 200
Pages maybe 210 or 20 tops
and like the whole books of Earthsea you
can get it in an Omnibus with all these
beautiful illustrations it's like a it's
like a thousand Pages yes so you're like
look at what she could accomplish in a
thousand Pages compared to I I don't
want to just bash Rawling because we
could talk about others but you know
Rawling takes 400 pages to write a book
about maybe maybe even longer sometimes
yeah and she she accomplishes less than
what the glean can do in one third of
the space this is a problem with all of
modern fantasy going back all the way I
would say into the you know early 2000s
is that brevity has been abandoned for
larger print sizes and everything else
and a lot of it comes from the fact that
implied meaning or implied plot or
implied characterization is just not
used as often because people don't trust
the readers and unfortunately literacy
levels are very low In America which
happens to be the biggest market and uh
another thing this is really interesting
interesting so I heard this from an
author who was published through one of
the main Publishers uh and they told me
the reason why Publishers like big books
is because it seems to be that consumers
will be more willing to spend the 17 or
2099 the books cost now okay when they
get the big book because a lot of books
like if you if Stephen King writes a 200
Page book it's still 24.99 right right
and they feel like they're getting a
better uh investment out of their money
or getting a better return out of their
money so that is one of the reasons why
specifically fantasy and sci-fi tend to
Trend to the bigger side but I read
Roger zelazny and I'm blown away right
yeah yeah uh the wit the themes the
dialogue that he's able to fit in 180
pages I mean these
you know I'm not one of these people to
think everything that's older is better
but I will say there's a lot of people
who can't hold a candle to Rogers lazny
uh and what he was doing in the 60s I
mean he's one of the best authors ever I
love Roger zelazny it's amazing yeah he
he was one of the people that was
um not only influential on me as a
reader but I used to I mean I did a
terrible job at this but when I was like
in the high school and college I wanted
to write poetry like Rogers lazny wrote
um prose didn't bring it off
but it was it was good to try right well
he does have like that uncanny ability
to just be very readable but not play in
any way I mean so distinct yeah what a
legend yeah you know let me get a a take
I know we're getting we've been talking
for a long time but I do want to be
cognizant of of the gift of time that
you're giving but so we got like the
first five books of the Amber Chronicles
right really really great stuff
imaginative it's this wonderful sweeping
panoramic thing with you know crazy
rides into Shadow and all this
machination back and forth and then in
the the final books you find out that
chaos is actually older than than Amber
and all this cool stuff and you get a
you know by the end of the fifth book
it's no longer just two polls there's a
new pattern in town right and then you
got the uh later on the next five books
um centered on Corwin's on Merlin who
you know is a computer guy and does some
other cool stuff he's also good with the
blade and he's got some friends of his
own and uh brother well some some half
brother if I remember right and then
also all these cousins and people like
that and it seems kind of fashionable to
bash the second set of five and say
they're not very good you know they're
he was kind of phoning it in at the time
to me I almost like the second set
better than the first set as somebody
who like really got into the first set
so I have not read the second set I am I
am not there yet so I this is uh my two
main series I'm finishing right now are
books of Amber and black company uh
which both by the way are shorter series
which is beautiful a lot of books but
short page counts yeah ever in the back
half um I read I've read uh books of
Amber the ones that uh from the first
Arc but I really fell in love with him
with Lord of Light yeah I mean all these
all these Standalone books you know I'm
so curious to see how I feel about the
back five of Amber because you're the
first person I've ever talked to that is
like I like them oh really well that's
no surprise though so many people I I
think it's almost like a Trope now you
know I agree dude that is so true that
is so so so so so true of books so many
people hate books four and five of A
Song of Ice and Fire and they're my
favorites because I actually think
George is doing like more complex things
yeah especially his thematic work uh
around feminism when it comes to like
Brienne of Tarth and uh Arya and stuff
like I think there's some really quality
stuff that happens in those books and
it's just a Trope online that everyone
says that they're not good because they
were split and I'm like I think they're
still good I think they're great so I'm
probably gonna be in your Camp I have a
feeling because me and you also have
very similar taste in books like any
time I fall in love with the series it
seems you've made a video about it and
like thank God because like I'll be like
what was that one part especially with
Prince of nothing I was like what what
happened there and then I'd go watch
your videos and by the way that's how I
found your channel was looking for uh
backer content okay I mean if we want to
be really facetious we could say you
know what happened there oh somebody got
raped honestly you wouldn't be wrong or
somebody got killed yeah
I got a great thing for us to go out on
um so with with George RR Martin right
it isn't all dark and dismal
um who would you say isn't the morally
best character across the board but
who's had the best
um like going from being a uh either you
know scummy or bad or just mediocre
person to actually being like a good
person
and and I don't mean good in the sense
of like you know a paladin you know oh
yeah yeah yeah butter wouldn't melt in
their mouth but like where you can say
okay I think that this person is
actually morally on on the rise
that is a tough one because my so the
person who I think has the best
potential is actually Theon Greyjoy oh
interesting but he's not there even as
as damaged as he is so you know we we
leave him where he jumps out of a window
with Sansa and you know the books are
different than the show this is one of
the biggest Divergence is that Sansa is
not um oh I'm sorry Jane pole is is in
Winterfell Sansa it was Sansa in the
show and they ruined her character but
uh Theon jumps out with Jane Poole and a
heroic act and his last chapter his
chapters in the book are called reek
until the last chapter is called Theon
and it's a sense of identity interesting
and uh by the way there's a beautiful
chapter in a dance of dragons uh called
the ghost in Winterfell where Theon is
sure that he is seeing and hearing a
ghost and the theory is is that it's
actually him it's his own conscious
speaking to him and it's a very weird
thing George is doing there so I would
say Theon but
we gotta see what happens next we gotta
see what happens next so honestly it's
Jamie Lannister even though he pushed a
kid out of the window George made him
somehow sympathetic and saving that POV
till book three was one of the smartest
things he has ever done as an author
I mean how brilliant is that because we
have been told Jamie is a you know King
Slayer this kingslayer that and then we
get we get the POV of him and we hear
about how he feels and we realize that
he killed the Mad King for good reasons
right and Ned Stark's still still put
him down for it even though the Mad King
lit his father and brother on fire and
it's like you know what this honor thing
isn't black and white is it and uh man
his relationship with Brian of Tarth
that was really telling but I also think
his relationship with Cersei which again
the show totally screwed up because he's
super screwed up he puts her aside he's
he's not going to go with her on stuff
he resists her and um yeah I I mean I
think he we'll have to see if Mark never
does publish the the next books
um what happens to him because you know
Martin could easily take him and send
him back out into the dumps and you
could do that in an interesting way by
the way I think circular character arcs
are actually uh they can be really
valuable and there could be change
within the monotony of the same mistake
you can make the mistake for a different
reason and I think that that's a really
compelling thing to do as an author
however the way it was done in the show
was garbage uh it was literally like uh
well I'll see you later Brian and then
it was garbage and I was just like this
is very unfortunate like this could have
worked still like you still could have
made it work but you didn't uh but we
know that those guys did they were over
their heads yeah so
well they thought they knew what they
were doing that's my problem and I'll
I'll get on my soapbox real quick
because because this is like go out on a
rant yeah so Dan and Dave uh got full of
themselves and people say well they ran
out of books they were good at adapting
random books that is not true they
started changing things from the books
in season three I mean they had other
changes and they left so much stuff out
that they could have used and they've
abandoned Dorne when the ratings went
down and and by the way the Dorn plot
they changed it they changed the door
plot it didn't do well and then p and
then automatically people said well
Dorn's not interesting I'm like if you
read the door and stuff in the books and
don't find it interesting then I don't
know what you're reading because I think
the door and stuff in the books is uh
fantastic like Oberyn Martell and the
whole crew I love them and uh by the way
how impressive is that in a book five
four book four to introduce a whole new
region a new cast of characters another
house and then find out that they were
working to try to get Daenerys with uh
you know um uh what's his name I'm
forgetting his name doesn't matter
um he ends up getting killed by a dragon
so whatever it's fine but uh you know
they just they fumbled it so it is not
that they ran out of material it is the
fact that they started changing things
before they ran out of material and then
they tried to still go with some of the
end points that Martin had given them
but like the road was messed up so
um I see people pin a lot of it on
George and I can understand the
frustration
um because we've been waiting a long
time but uh that television shows finale
was solely on the people who wrote those
episodes so I would say everything from
uh the second to last season was all of
them yeah yeah and and you know it's
funny there's still some moments in that
fan final season like Brienne being like
those things like there are still things
that are so good because of the build up
to them but it's just they did not end
the story and they abandoned a lot of
the Fantastical really had a snobby
attitude towards fantasy which I didn't
like as well
um as a fantasy fan you know they said
they wanted to make a show for uh soccer
moms is what they said they don't care
about the fantasy and
it's like you know I think people don't
trust in the fact that people can
suspend their their belief their
disbelief for a while you know yeah
yeah and you know I'll just say this I
realize we're going on and on and out
there are some series like Earth seed
right very difficult to adapt properly
oh yeah
um you know
Martin Could Have A Song of Ice and Fire
I think could have done could have been
done well yeah under under different
management because none of the elements
within it are too tricky to represent
adequately you know no they're really
not and George also wrote uh for
television back in the 80s in twilight
zone right right and uh they they lifted
the dialogue word for word out of the
book because George wrote TV type of
dialogue right next time next time you
read the books pay attention to the fact
that every single chapter begins in the
middle of an action just like a TV show
interesting you come in the middle of a
scene you never get like the horse buggy
went up the road and then came the
castle we made our way through the gate
never it is like pass me the tea darling
and you're like wait who's talking you
know what I mean so it's like yeah he
starts things in the middle just like
they do in television shows so his his
stuff was very adaptable and it's clear
from the first three seasons Four
Seasons uh that it worked yep
uh all right well you have been very
generous with your your time on a
late uh August evening and uh thanks for
for coming on
um just for for people to find you
obviously the the YouTube channel is one
of the best plays the fantasy networks
put it into Google
um is there anything else that you want
to walk uh get out there people should
check out because I'll put it in the
video description yeah certainly so I do
a A Song of Ice and Fire podcast it is
my favorite series and it's called bend
the knee and you can find us on anywhere
you can get Podcast I also host a
Stormlight Archive uh read along podcast
which is Brandon sanderson's Epic
Fantasy series and it's called Lost in
roshar it's again available on all
podcasts and then of course my YouTube
channel is the fantasy Network which is
n-u-t-t-w-r-r-r-o-r-k sorry it's a
dyslexia coming in uh and then I also
and I don't know if anyone would be
interested in this but I do run a manga
Channel Japanese comic books I run a
manga Channel called dudes talking manga
and it's actually my biggest project at
this point oh wow it just I made it with
a friend as almost a joke and now it's
it's getting like 30 000 views every
video and I'm like What's Happening like
I don't know what's happening
um I tried out Japanese Comics like on a
whim and I was like this is kind of cool
like yeah like this I always thought
that it was very you know a lot of the
anime stuff rubs me the wrong way and
the over sexualization of it and then I
found out that just like fantasy there's
a ton of like you know the variety in
there so I've been diving into that so
if anyone's in the manga you can come
check out these talking manga but I'm a
bit I'm a busy guy I like to keep busy
talk about nerd things and uh man I just
want to thank you for inviting me on uh
oh [__] I watched your content for like
so long and then to be able to bring you
on chatting with nuts uh my my kind of
General reform show on the fantasy
Network and then being able to come on
this I mean this is uh This is Wild to
me because I think you make some great
stuff and I like talking to you so yeah
I like talking to you too this turned
out really really good I I think so
absolutely
all right well again thanks thanks for
being here and uh we'll probably cross
paths uh soon in the future yes Philip K
dick talk that's right